parla a neighborhood that had been a
haven for Dutch immigrants a cultural
mecca for creative african-americans for
decades had evolved into a vibrant and
diverse Enclave in the midst of the
modern metropolis of New York but it had
a new challenge to face
[Music]
corner of vine come holla nice about
this much sense at Sylvia's restaurant
Lord vegan the offensive O'Brien's
presence in the neighborhood were felt
immediately after he arrived at the
venerable Apollo Theater a freak Banana
Republic factory stores fountains that
stood in the streets something sinister
was taking place
only created such nothing he basically
turned a traditionally black
neighborhood into a black hole I always
thought I'd take my last breath right
here on 127th and the home I was born in
but since that gangly jackets came in
new jersey's looking pretty good well
I'm back in Los Angeles now so that
should tell you how bad things got if
you're seeing this in New York
that's not Andy on stage it's my brother
Pete he's fatter than me in the days to
come the Apollo Theater was removed from
the Register of Historic Landmarks the
rooster had indeed landed and now Harlem
one sprite once grande was covered in
bird [ __ ]
let's head for Andy's brother we'll be
right back
[Applause]
you